who got attacked who should be smacked
and which couple could be gone for good
all that and so much more on Sweetwater
secrets
[Music]
welcome back vixens I'm Liana Galera
you're HBIC of all things Riverdale and
this is the after-show for chapter 18
when a stranger calls you know called
you on the phone repeatedly so you know
the drill
spoilers are ahead you all the red sour
emojis I mean they're all right here
okay now this was the most jam-packed
episode of the season and we have so
much to discuss
from jugheads salacious serpent behavior
to the black hoods blackmailing threats
+ KJ APPA weighs in on Veronica's ex
coming to town and Madeline Pett spills
her top hisses and kisses from the
episode and she reveals what's next for
Sheryl after that truly traumatic night
so let's get all this started with the
top headlines of the week in the blue
and gold breakdown alright guys first up
the black hood is calling and calling
and calling and Betty keeps answering
yes he spent the entire episode
blackmailing Betty which included
picking a vicious fight with Veronica
and breaking up with Jughead via Archie
which was super awkward and it all ended
on a really creepy note when he forced
Betty to put a hood on herself left that
was no no this is bad really bad next
the Serpent's have a new member
tired of being half a cent and juggy was
determined to keep the peace between the
north side and the south side and this
was his solution now the initiation was
intensely bizarre yes there was even a
snake bite sleep in True Blood but in
the end Jughead beat his way into the
Serpent's ranks literally
and lastly a blast from Veronica's past
Nick st. Clair came to Riverdale as
you've nothing to worry about and it
turns out Archie and the rest of our
milkshake loving gang had a lot to worry
about because Nick st. Clair is a drug
doing peer pressuring roofie slippin
douchebag
now after trying and failing to hook up
with Veronica Nick turned his predatory
sites on to Cheryl luckily our Pussycats
have some ferocious claws and they
smacked and kicked and punched that smug
smile right off his face and Betty
delivered the final cherry on top
Nick st. Clair now this was a truly
harrowing episode and the topic of
sexual abuse is eerily relevant right
now so here's what Madeline Pech had to
say about this episode's events this
week's episode was so intense yeah when
you read the script for it and you found
out that Cheryl was gonna be getting
roofied by Nick st. Claire what was your
reaction I'll be honest I cried really I
cried I called my mom I was like this is
like I didn't tell her what happened
obviously but I was like this is like
it's a really heavy episode this is a
huge topic especially right now with
what's going on in the world and it's so
close to home and it's so important to
you know portray it properly I felt like
a huge responsibility to make it real
and but then also there was a part of me
that was just my heart was breaking so
it was a very interesting moment for me
to get that and there was no warning
coming of course it makes sense for us
to be you know bringing these things to
light I think it's very rare for TV
shows to be doing that especially ones
that are more geared towards younger
fans and I think it's important to kind
of you know let them know what's going
on in the world and all of that kind of
stuff but at the same time it's just
like it's it's hard you as the person
who plays the character and like as
somebody who roots for the character
every single time that I got a script
it's it's brutal you're a pig
alright guys now it's time to move on to
seven seconds in heaven now this
passionate pops kiss between jug and
Betty was our bright light and a
devastatingly dark episode but it was
quickly snuffed out when the black hood
made Betty break up a jug and then Betty
made Archie do her dirty work for her
not cool girl just look at this sad
little face he's so upset
don't Betty I got the message now
unfortunately for all the bug he had
fans out there Jughead also locked lips
with Tony this episode which kiss was
better hit the comments right now and
tell me all right guys now over in
barchi news things were extremely tense
with Nick st. Claire practically
drooling all over Veronica right in
front of our chief just when I thought
you couldn't possibly get any sexier now
take a look at what KJ Appa had to tell
me when we talked about those extra
awkward moments the picture yeah what
does Archie have to say I don't think
it's anything to say I'm sure they just
stuff to do about it for sure
I reckon yeah maybe it can't be please
no actually out of all the people would
be that one that kind of would be really
unhappy about that
is he a jealous boyfriend I wouldn't
define him as being a jealous boyfriend
but I think I mean I think for sure if
your partner has history with someone
else and you know you see them you know
getting closer intimate in any kind of
way there's definitely gonna be a hint
of something coming out you know what I
mean yeah he likes to say he gets what
he deserves in the end damn right he got
what he deserved and this leads us into
this week's hisses and kisses all right
guys I'm hurling multiple hisses to the
bug head break up Tony's rebound smooch
and just to jugheads general behavior in
this episode so many lies and not enough
fries my friend hisses to having to
watch bitter Betty start that
gut-wrenching B&V fight and to the
Riverdale sound editors for making me
hate the lollipop song
I used to love that song and now I can't
even look at lollipops anymore lastly
this hiss is going out to Veronica for
giving in to Nick's peer pressure and
encouraging everyone to do jingle jangle
every other night it's burgers and
milkshakes can't we just cut loose and
pretend we're normal for once
news flash Vee doing drugs is not quote
normal behavior and honestly I'm really
disappointed that that line made it into
a show with such a young impressionable
fanbase now not to get all preachy on
you river babes but seriously don't do
drugs it's not worth it just watch
Riverdale and watch these videos instead
okay you're gonna get the same hi babe
moving on to kisses this kiss is going
to the fact that Jughead and hot dog
finally came together now for all you
non Archie comic fans out there hot dog
is kind of a big deal and I was excited
to see him every new recruit has to take
care of hot dogging station another kiss
goes to my girl Alice Cooper for
breezing into the lodge party and
embracing the sultry serpent that she
truly is and for giving us the best line
of the night
shove it hell yeah shove it black hood I
mean how sorry kisses - our second
Pussycats performance of the season and
a last kiss - the fact that we got our
first sneak peek of a new romance now I
revealed a comic-con that Josie and
Reggie are going to become a
full-fledged couple later this season
and I'll have more from Ashley Marie and
Charles Melton on that subject soon
until then what are we gonna call them
judging Rosie ooh
like Rosie hit the comments with your
favorite stripper names right now
alright guys moving on to cap off this
week's kisses and kisses we have some
special guest commentary that's right
Madeleine Pech aka preferred a resident
at grocery awesome weighed in with her
hisses ooh kisses I've already got a hit
okay
I hate Nick st. Clare yeah he could
possibly burn somewhere and I wouldn't
be upset let's stick him in Thornhill
before I burn it
yeah rewind you want Nick to pay to
suffer to burn in hell
I hate Nick st. Clare more than I hate
miss Grundy that's odd Nick's
a monster and I would not be that upset
if he suffered the same fate
what were you kisses for this episode my
kiss is girl power when I read this
script in some of the Pussycats and
Veronica save Cheryl I thought it was
such a fun moment for all the girls to
get together
- Betty obviously she's got more
important things to deal with but I just
thought it was such a great moment and I
were shooting that it was just so epic
and it was um it was like a really great
moment like for girls who don't always
get along by the way to like get
together and like stand up for each
other and like for girls to always be
into her sides but I think that was a
really great moment and I think he
deserved a good ass kickings Oh
completely and when she says girls who
don't get along she means their
characters not in real life yeah I'll
get it love each other back I got your
back I later that was going now it's
time to hear from you guys share your
kisses and kisses from this week's
episode in the comments below and you
can be featured on the next episode and
tune in next time for a Sweetwater
secrets preview episode of 206 chapter
19 death Proof because I'll have behind
the scenes scoop from Camilla Mendes and
Lilly Reinhardt talking all about B and
V's fight plus a special look at how
cami and Lilly's real-life best
friendship first began so you don't want
to miss that and if you guys had fun
with me please give this video a like
and hit subscribe on et's youtube
channel and of course click the link in
my description below to ring the bell so
you never miss an episode of Sweetwater
secrets see you next time river babes
[Music]
you